c'est l'heure de notre second débat
second débat de ce sens public qui porte
sur l'inflation elle se maintient à des
niveaux élevés près de 5 % en août par
rapport au mois d'août de l'année
précédente le pouvoir d'achat des
Français baisse la pauvreté augmente le
gouvernement évidemment cherche des
solutions Elisabeth borne a notamment
annoncé vouloir interdire la
shrinkflation cette manipe de certaines
marques qui réduisent la quantité de
produits dans un emballage sans réduire
le prix ben je sais pas on va dire 330 g
de céréales dans un paquet qui en
faisait 400 auparavant Audrey
vas au premier coup d'œil ces deux
boîtes de lit en poudre sont identiques
même emballage même taille mais leur
poids est bien différent 900 g de
produits dans l'une 830 dans l'autre
moins de produits vendu plus cher au
kilo donc la technique porte le nom de
shrink FL contraction du mot inflation
et de shrink réduire en anglais papier
toilette les clip tout ça tout a diminué
de d'épaisseur et cetera donc ça se voit
ils augmentent les prix mais il baissent
la qualité alors et la quantité donc
c'est vraiment n'importe quoi ah ben
c'est pas bon quoi il profite quoi c'est
pas normal quoi une méthode qui passe
mal chez les clients en cette période
d'inflation mais qui est pourtant
utilisé depuis les années 2000 par les
industriels pour changer de recette
maintenir des prix fixes voire même
faire des économies ce jour-là
l'enseigne Carrefour a décidé de les
montrer du doigt à avec ses affichettes
oranges ce sont des affichettes qui vous
donnent l'information que le produit qui
est présenté devant vous et bien a fait
l'objet de schringflation si on vous le
dit pas vous ne le savez pas et nous on
a considéré que dans notre enseigne on
avait construit une relation avec nos
clients qui étaai basé enfin qui est
basé sur de la confiance et de la
transparence et c'est la raison pour
laquelle on a souhaité identifier 26
produits dans l'ensemble de nos rayons
qui sont concernés par de la
shrinflation un coup de comm
communication en tout 26 produits sont
concernés sur les milliers de références
que compte le magasin je sais pas si ça
changera grand-chose ça peut peut-être
changer les rapports de force au moment
des négociations de prix entre
industriel et distributeurs ce débat
vient en pleine négociation commerciale
l'inflation est forte plus de 20 % sur 2
ans il y a des demandes de renégociation
de terminer pour les industriels
probablement avant la fin de l'année ou
peut-être mi-janvier donc tout ça est un
jeu aussi de communication il y a un jeu
d'information légitime vis-à-vis des
consommateurs mais il y a aussi un jeu
de communication des relations industrie
commerce et faut pas en être dupe de son
côté le gouvernement s'est emparé du
sujet Bruno Le Maire le ministre de
l'Économie promet un projet de loi d'ici
le mois prochain pour forcer les
industriels à communiquer quand ils
rétrécissent leurs produits comment
freiner l'inflation pourra-t-on
retrouver un jour les prix de 2021 tiens
pourquoi pas on en débat avec ericyer
bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue à vous êtes
direct directeur du département analyse
et prévisions de l'Observatoire français
les conjonctures économiques Pascal
etbell bonsoir bienvenue à vous aussi
vous êtes économiste directrice associé
au cabinet de conseil en marketing
Seaways rodolp bonas bonsoir bonsoir le
PDG du groupe aristi retil technologie
spécialiste de la grande distribution on
est également au téléphone avec
Anne-Catherine Loisier qui est
sénatriste Union centriste de la Côte
d'Or vice-président de la commission des
affaires économiques et rapporteur des
lois égal c'était en 2018 et vous êtes
en ce moment rapporteur du Comité de
suivi de la loi Galim on y viendra tout
à l'heure bonsoir et merci à vous
Matthieu croissandau éitoraliste
politique est resté à mes côtés on
rebondit sur le le sujet d'ouverture de
ce débat pour commencer avec ce mot
horrible shrink flesion Erer du mot
rétrécir en en anglais j'ai pas encore
trouvé de de mot français il va falloir
qu'on travaille un peu pardon arnaque ah
oui ça on pourrait ça ça c'est sûr
arnaque ça on on est d'accord quand on
fait les rayons du supermarché c'est le
sentiment qu'on a est-ce que c'est
nouveau tiens al je pouris pas répondre
a une grande précision là-dessus mais
oui j'imagine que tout même c'est une
une façon de d'aborder les choses mais
normalement l'INC doit être un peu
vigilante lorsqu'elle calcule puisquelle
essaie de regarder bah l'augmentation
des produits mais à qualité donnée et
aussi à quantité donnée donc ça de ça
normalement doit être pris en compte
dans l'indice des prix à la consommation
donc ça c'est ce qui est fourni tous les
mois par l'INC alors ensuite dans des
magasins est-ce que le consommateur fait
bien la différence entre la quantité
qu'il avait avant et et et ensuite ça
c'est un peu plus compliqué parce
qu'elle est belle c'est c'est légal
parce que le le prix à l'unité enfin est
noté sur le sur l'emballage c'est c'est
c'est ça c'est là-dessus que je joue les
marques moi il y a une question que je
me pose parce que là on voit depuis
quelques semaines on va dire quelques
jours pas mal de reportages un peu comme
le nôtre qui font la démonstration pour
une marque c'est calamiteux en terme
d'image donc quand on sait à quel point
les marques sont sensibles à leur image
aujourd'hui com pourquoi font-elles ça
quoi alors ça vient vraiment d'un décret
de 2007 avant on avait pas le droit en
fait et puis en 2007 au niveau européen
un décret a permis de faire ce qu'on
voulait sur les conditionnements et
c'est à ce moment-là et comme on était
en pleine crise économique 2008 il y a
déjà des marques qui sont faites
épingler moi je me souviens une marque
française une grande marque française et
à ce momentlà elle a été obligée de
s'excuser c'était les premiers cas et là
on voit aujourd'hui qu'ils sont un peu
plus décomplexés ils s'excusent pas
tellement et en effet c'est une façon de
de vendre des portions plus petites et
le consommateur s'en rend pas compte
mais c'est légal parce que vous avez
toujours un affichage de prix au kilo
dans les rayons ce qui est obligatoire
maintenant c'est des prix au kilos donc
si vous comparer en regardant les prix
au kilo et c'est ce qu'on conseille au
consommateurs et bien entendu on se fait
moins avoir mais en effet là c'est
vraiment une question de communication
et si c'est dénoncé c'est bien parce
qu'en ce moment il y a des négociations
donc ça c'est pour dénigrer les marques
qui l'ont fait rol bon ça concerne assez
peu de produits dans dans nos
hypermarchés aujourd'hui oui aujourd'hui
assez peu de produit savoir que cette
technique était précédemment utilisée
plutôt pour faire en sorte que
l'industriel arrive à quelque part
augmenter son prix sans augmenter la
valeur faciale d'achat pour une raison
très très simple c'est que les
consommateurs sont extrêmement attentifs
au prix unitaire des produits qu'ils
achètent et donc c'estit un bon moyen de
dire bon j'augmente mes prix mais pour
le consommateur ça va pas augmenter le
ticket de caisse là ce mais Mathie
disait arnaque enfin ça y ressemble ça y
ressemble quand même beaucoup sur le
principe alors là le point c'est que la
raison pour laquelle tout ce débat s'est
fortement enflammé c'est que en fait ici
on est dans une situation où c'est un
peu la double peine c'est-à-dire que non
seulement on a ce dispositif dans lequel
on réduit les quantités et mais en plus
on va augmenter le prix c'est-à-dire
qu'on a une un double effet k scoule
c'està-dire on utilise le le contexte de
l'inflation pour dire écoutez on va
augmenter nos prix de 10 % et à côté de
cela on va diminuer les quantités de 10
% donc là c'est vrai que l'addition est
un peu salée à avaler pour les
consommateurs alors pardon parce qu'il y
vair plein d'anglicisme dans ce dans ce
débat il y en a un autre ericyer c'est
la la grid flleashion alors là c'est le
mot avidité euh en en anglais de de quoi
on parle bah normalement vous
généralement vous augmentez les prix à
peu près à du proportion des de
l'augmentation de de vos coûts les coûts
salariaux ou les les coûts des
consommations intermédiaires pour garder
des marges à peu près identiques bah là
ce qu'on constate alors pas partout mais
dans beaucoup euh de de secteurs c'est
que là les prix ont augmenté beaucoup
plus que les coûts et donc c'est donc ça
veut dire que des entreprises
répercutent des hausses plus importantes
important pour augmenter
ex et ça on le voit notamment dans
l'industrie agroalimentaire où les taux
de marge de de dans ce secteur a
fortement bondi voyez si vous prenez
comme référence plutôt 2018 que 2019
pourquoi parce que 2019 il y a eu le
double cice c'est un peu compliqué ça ça
donc ça augmenté mais donc prenons le
cas de par rapport à 2018 aujourd'hui
dans l'industrie agroalimentaire ils
sont 7 points de de de marge au-dessus
donc c'est assez remarquable dans
l'énergie ils sont plutôt aux alentour
de 18 points de de de de Mar auudessus
donc c'est c'est assez gigantesque et
donc ça ça alimente l'inflation et quand
vous regardez juste la la dernière année
c'est la dernière année le facteur qui
explique le plus qui contribue le plus à
l'augmentation des prix vous avez soit
les coûts salariaux soit les
consommations intermédiaires soit les
taxes soit les les les marges et ben ce
sont les marges les marges qui
expliquent le plus la contribution au
prix de production enfin au prix de
production ensuite après dans ces prix
de production il y a une partie qui va
dans les prix de consommation donc
effectivement ça c'est pas que français
puisque
ès disantention en Europe la est sans
doute un des élé qui explique le
plusutrelcisme je vais essayer de pas
englisser partout j'en ai mis TR en 5
minutes name and ça veut dire quoi
nommer une entreprise la dénoncer pour
qu'elle est
honte ça peut marcher pour les l'arnaque
sur les emballages et et le poids ou le
prix du produit et pour ça aussi bah
bien sûr ça marche pour tout ça marche
aussi pour je vais vous rajouter un
terme un autre si vous permettez
c'est est vraiment désolé mais ça
s'appelle la CHIP FL mais c'est
exactement le même donc là c'est des
produits qui sont de moins bonne qualité
vendus vous remplacez le beurre par la
margarine par exemple vous faites de la
CHIP flion mais c'est pas parfois très
difficile pour les consommateurs de
l'identifier parce qu'il faut retourner
là pour le coup pas forcément voir le
prix au litre au prix au quilo mais faut
regarder là les les les ingrédients qui
constituent le produit mais vous avez
tout à fait raison le ne and Chems là
encore un angicisme et c'est un petit
peu ce que ce que montrer ici et ce que
fait Carrefour finalement dans sa rayon
c'est de mettre en exer certaines
marques pour dire à ses consommateur
attention ici selon nous il dépasse les
bornes alors dans ce débat on essaie de
de savoir quelle est la la la marge
d'action les leviers d'action d'un d'un
gouvernement en l'occurrence du
gouvernement français Catherine Loisier
je me tourne vers vous une première fois
puisque la la première ministre a
annoncé vouloir interdire cette shrink
flation elle parle de procédés choquant
bon ben oui marquer les sauf que en fait
si on regarde bien ce que nous propose
Elisabeth borne elle dit marquer les
produits concernés les signaler au
consommateurs ça veut dire plutôt
encadrer qu'un interdire est-ce que ça
suffit pour vous bah comme l'a évoqué
précédente intervenante je je c'est
c'est c'est une méthode qui est
aujourd'hui autorisé et qui est légale
ce qui est choquant c'est l'absence de
transparence et quelque part peut-être
la la la tromperie vis-à-vis du
consommateur qui souvent en fait a un
prix psychologique en tête hein sur
beaucoup de de produits il y a le le le
consommateur se fixe des des des des des
montants plafonds et pour rester sous
prix psychologique et un certain nombre
de de d'industriels ou de de de
producteurs diminu pardon les les
quantité donc effectivement la PR la
question c'est est-ce qu'il faut
l'interdire est-ce qu'il faut aller plus
loin que ce que N moi je ne pense pas
qu'il faille l'interdire mais je pense
qu'il faut qu'il y ait toute la
transparence aujourd'hui on sait bien
que l'ensemble des consommateurs ne
regarde pas forcément le prix au kilo ou
la référence et donc il faut qu'il y ait
de la transparence pour que le
consommateur B s'il fait voilà s tient
ce produit et qui qui veut vraiment en
acheter même en moindre quantité au même
prix il le fasse en toute connaissance
de cause après moi je voudrais dire
quand même contre parfois les triis
pratiqué par les distributeurs et le
prix de vente de l'industriel nous ce
qui nous a été rapporté en tout cas dans
le cadre de N nos travaux de de suivi
c'est que c'est pas toujours la même
chose et que parfois les distributeurs
peuvent pratiquer des prix plus
importants sur un certain nombre de
marques euh voilà pour des motifs diff
parfois c'est pour favoriser leur leur
que distributeur mais je je voudrais
quand même dire qu'il faut pas forcément
incriminer systématiquement l'industriel
qui a sa part de responsabilité mais qui
a aussi ces dernières années les
industriels ont globalement fait face à
des grosses chutes de leur Marg et
aujourd'hui dans un cont on y reviendra
en détail pardon de N interromp mais on
y reviendra un peu plus tard et je vous
redonnerai la parole sur sur ce thème je
je reviens à la question de la marge de
manœuvre d'un d'un d'un gouvernement
voilà sur ces différents je vais pas
redonner tous les anglicistes procédés
qu'on a qu'on qu'on a détaillé mais cé
important de les détailler je pense au
début de ce ce débat est-ce que c'est
enfin voilà interdire la shwing FL
est-ce que c'est possible ou est-ce que
c'est totalement illusoire aujourd'hui
il peut pas puisque c'est un décret
européen ça serait ça prendrait du temps
en fait de de de faire remonter ça au
niveau européen donc en effet la seule
chose qu'il peut faire c'est rendre
obligatoire un affichage quoi en fait
qui annonce un changement sur le
packaging mais obligé sur ce thème là et
pas sur d'autres thèmes il faudrait
l'obliger sur la la composition c'est
c'est compliqué donc je sais pas très
bien ce que va proposer Elizabeth B on
va avoir beaucoup de choses à lire sur
nos
emballages si on commence mais
heureusement plus plus la transparence
souvent d'ailleurs le QR code est une
est une porte vers une une transparence
accrue Mathieu sur ce thème de
l'inflation vous parler d'une on va dire
une conversion au sommet de l'État oui
alors sur le thème de l'inflation sur le
thème de la politique budgétaire ou
économique en général je vous propose de
jouer au je des petite phrase qui a dit
les super profits je sais pas ce que
c'est c'est une notion qui n'a pas de
sens Bruno Le Maire notre ministre de
l'Économie c'était il y a 1 an au devant
la réunion des entrepreneurs de France
donc le grand raout du meddeef estival
maintenant qui a dit nous voulons
récupérer les surprofits qui ont été
faits par les compagnies d'autoroute je
crois qu'il pH juste derrière voilà le
même Bruno Le Maire sur LCI la semaine
dernière alors vous me direz il y a que
les imbéciles qui ne changent pas d' vie
c'est vrai mais ce virage à 180°r ne
reste pas moins spectaculaire
expliquez-nous pourquoi voltef mais
parce que le contexte politique a changé
d'abord il y a un an Emmanuel Macron de
se faire rélire mais attention il
n'avait pas eu la majorité à l'Assemblée
nationale et la gauche forte de son bon
score législative tentait de pousser son
avantage et elle n'avait que la taxation
des super profits à la bouche de quoi
donner des soires froides et au
gouvernement et aux investisseurs un an
plus tard la donne a un peu changé parce
qu'on est plus tellement dans
l'affichage politique mais dans le
bouclage budgétaire et cette idée de
taxer les entreprise qui profitent de la
crise pour gonfler leur marge ou qui
pour faire des des surprofit a fait son
chemin parce que ça permet de récupérer
de l'argent sans trop de douleur dans le
cas des autoroutes en particulier mais
la question des marges de ces profiteurs
de crise est aussi devenu un argument
pour faire pression on l'a vu dans les
négociations avec les industriels et les
distributeurs Nau le maire menaçait
d'utiliser l'arme budgétaire attention
il y a le budget qui se discute à
l'automne voilà pointer les bénéfices
pour demander un effort mais pas trop
non plus pour ne pas faire trop peur
bref c'est une ligne de crête mais
qu'emprunte le ministre de l'Économie
désormais ouis on peut dire qu'il joue
quand même assez gros politiquement dans
cette lutte contre l'inflation oui parce
qu'il en va de sa crédibilité de
ministre de l'Économie bien sûr mais
aussi sans doute un peu de son avenir
politique lui qui rêve de 2027 même s'il
le dit un peu moins fort que certains de
ses collègues or si la France n'a pas à
rougir de son bilan en matière
d'inflation quand on la compare à ses
voisins européens ben ça fait une belle
jambe au français au moment de remplir
son cadit parce qu'il voit le ministre
s'agiter certes mais il voit les
additions flambé alors souvent critiqué
par les oppositions et par les réseaux
sociaux qui l'ont même à fublé du surnom
de Bruno demande parce que Bruno Le
Maire demande mais ne contraint pas et
ben le ministre de l'économie pourrait
trouver avec cette taxation des
surprofits si jamais elle se fait pour
les autoroutes et si jamais elle pouvait
se faire sur d'autres secteur le surnom
de Bruno obtien qu'il espère tant si on
pouvait m'appeler Bruno obtien PL que
Bruno BR demandecment mais cette
conversion en tout cas elle est
peut-être pas pour tout de suite parce
qu'elle est belle la taxe sur les
profits ou les surprofits des autoroutes
c'est la plus peut-être la plus simple
je mets plein de guillemets par s' y a
des des des salariés de Prut il vont
dire qu'est-ce qu'il nous dit celui-là
c'est peut-être la plus simple à mettre
en place oui celle qui qui va pouvoir se
se mettre en place on se souvient qu'il
y avait eu la demande sur total aussi en
fait hein sur des groupes d'énergie
peut-être que là c'est aussi plus facile
la mettre sur les entreprises
agroalimentaires c'est un secteur qui
est beaucoup plus éclaté en fait c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué de définir
quelle est l'entreprise qui aura comment
comment va se comment va se calculer
d'ailleurs cette taxe en fait he si si
si je reprends pardon si je reprends les
les les annonces qui avaient été faites
par Bruno Le Maire avant
l'été on disait ben ça va commencer à
baisser en septembre on n est pas
vraiment hein donc pourquoi comment
comment ça se souvient très bien du
fameux pic de l'inflation hein c'estd ça
y est le pic de l'inflation alors c'est
vrai qu'aujourd'hui on a alors
l'inflation c'est un dispositif un peu
compliqué quelque part parce que en fait
quand on comme vous le savez quand on
dit l'inflation baisse en fait c'est pas
les finalement elle ralenti hein
c'estàdire que les les prix continuent
malheureusement à augmenter mais à un
niveau qui est un peu un peu moins vite
pourquoi parce qu'il y a des éléments
constitutifs de cette inflation qui sont
par exemple les salaires qui vont pas
rebaisser donc mécaniquement ou d'autres
qui font que ça ne rebaisse pas donc oui
ce qu'on peut dire quand même c'est que
sur le fond de l'alimentaire on a on
commence à avoir des baisses de prix sur
certaines catégories de produits et plus
particulièrement sur les marques
distributeurs c'està dire que les
marques distributeurs vous savez c'est
ces produits qui sont élaborés en
partenariat entre les distributeurs et
des entreprises agroalimentaires de plus
petite taille et donc là oui sur ce
marché on commence à avir des prix qui
commence à baisser en rayon j'ouvre une
parenthèse parce que je je vis bien
répondre à une des question que j'ai
posé au début de ce débat l'hypothèse de
revenir au prix d'avant ça ça marche
jamais ça parce je P c'est la question
quand même plus le plus posé pendant les
pendant les vacances moi c'est vrai non
les prix ça a été indiqué les prix il y
AA un phénomène de marge escalier les
prix étaient ici il y a eu l'inflation
ça les amis ici et là l'inflation
continue mais moins fortement donc ça
veut dire ça va progresser moins
fortement mais vous allez jamais revenir
là il faudrait qu'on rentre dans ce
qu'on appelle de la déflation c'estàdire
que l'inflation négative mais il faut
l'oublier ça voyez parce que sur les
matières premières voyez de depuis à peu
près 2008 effectivement quand vous
prenez les 19 matières premières qui
sont échangé qu' soit énergétique
alimentaire et cetera il y avait bien
effectivement des baisses de prix
d'accord ça marchait par palier on était
descendu de d' peu près 30 % entre 2014
2019 et encore 30 % là on est repassé
au-dessus et ça va pas baisser voyz donc
on est j'ai juste une question de béen
le le blé il a baissé par exemple le
début de Raon donc d'accord donc il y a
un effet marge escalier ça a un tout
petit peu baissé mais on est encore très
auus
estér Mo eff ça baissé mais c'est
l'avantise la marge escalier est
gigantesque donc ça va être ça et ça je
pense qu'il faut le garder
macroéconomiquement les prix vont faire
une marge escalier donc faut que les
salaires suivent alors les revenus il
faut que les revenus suivent alors les
revenus et donc les salairesy le
problème c'est la rapidité et la hauteur
de cette marge escalier faut pas se
prendre le pied dans la marche escalier
il faut lever énormément la marche la
jamb du coup les salaires les les
entreprises nous disent c'est pas
possible qu'on qu'on mette cette même
marge d' escalier sur les salaires sinon
là c'est la spirale qui s'enclenche
parce qu'on va devoir le répercuter et
donc ça veut dire que l'État aide soit
soit par des primes et en défiscalisant
un certain nombre de primes soit par par
du revenus le problème et ça je pense
que c'est assez important c'est que le
jour où l'inflation revient à 2 % les
prix ne seront pas revenus encore une
fois elles ont Contin à progresser c'est
là on va dire c'est bon on est sorti de
la crise l'inflation
on peut enlever toutes les aides les
primes ne seront pas reconduites et un
certain nombre de dispositifs vont être
et c'est là où la marge escalier sur les
revenus va être significatif et c'est là
où la crise sociale va arriver ouais
annecatherine Loisier en sur cette
question des revenus et des salaire on a
bien compris la la la
distinction qu'est-ce que vous proposez
qu'est-ce que vous attendez du
gouvernement dans sa capacité parce que
c'est pas le gouvernement qui décide à
faire pression sur sur les entreprises
ou je pense que globalement en tout cas
dans dans dans l'alimentaire pour celle
qu'on a pu interroger la plupart ont
pratiquau ou sont en cours de de de
pratiquer cette augmentation de salaire
autour des 4 et demi pour pour. il y a
un autre marge d'escalier qui me semble
importante c'est toutes les contraintes
liées au changement climatique par
exemple aussi à la responsabilité des
des des par exemple au recyclage vous
savez la loiilité é lgie du producteur
ouais voilà et tout ça va amener
forcément dès l'année 2024 euh des des
des contraintes et des investissements
supplémentaires pour ces entreprises
ouais euh sur cette question de euh des
salaires moi j'ai souvent entendu
attention au risque de spirale prix
salaire c'est il faut l'expliquer euh
est-ce que est-ce que c'est une des
raisons pour lesquelles on hésite à
augmenter les salaires aussi aussi vite
que les PR oui quand on prend par
exemple le prix d'une baguette le prix
du blé c'est que 10 % en fait donc en
fait tout le reste c'est le salaire de
ceux qui fabriquent le pain donc si euh
même si le prix du blé a été divisé par
2 c'est un peu le cas et bien le les 90
% de du salaire du boulanger si ça
augmente bien le prix de la baguette ne
peut pas diminuer c'est en fait c'est ça
la spirale inflationniste et c'est ce
qui peut se passer c'est un petit peu ce
que disent aussi tous les industriels de
l'agroalimentaire que l'énergie continue
d'augmenter parce que ce qui se passe en
ce moment c'est que le relais se fait
par le prix du pétrole les prix de
l'alimentation en effet ça commence un
petit peu à baisser et et donc pour
fabriquer des biens alimentaires on a
aussi de l'énergie et du salaire donc
forcément c'est compliqué de de baisser
les prix et en terme de d'impact de du
changement climatique on sait que les
récoltes en fait elles vont subir des
accoups tout le temps donc c'est pas que
les investissements pour la transition
écologique c'est qu'on va avoir des
récoltes on sait qu'il y a eu un dome de
chaleur encore au Canada donc on va
avoir encore des des problèmes
d'approvisionnement en blé en tournesol
et tout ce qui a touché finalement les
hausses de prix estce que ce qu'on en
train d'annoncer c'est que les Français
verront jamais leur salairire augmenté
dans dans les années qui viennent que
quand ça va pas on peut pas les
augmenter quand ça va mieux il faut
reconstiuer les marges et quand ça va
mieux bah il faut pas déclencher
l'inlation non mais c'est important il
va falloir que au bout du bout du bout
les salaires et progressé de la même
manière que les prix avec la marge
escalier le problème c'est la rapidité
dans lequelle vous allez d'accord donc
ça veut dire que aujourd'hui les
salaires ont progressé en Nino mais
moins que l'inflation donc il y a une
perte de pouvoir d'achat et donc il va
falloir que pendant des années les
salaires progressent plus vite que
l'inflation pendant un certain nombre
d'années pour récupérer là pour
l'instant on a perdu à peu près 2 points
et demi et ben il faut récupérer 2
points et demi l'idée c'est à quelle
vitesse si vous le faites trop vite il y
a une spirale inflationniste les banques
centrales augmentent les T l'intérêt ça
provoque une récession donc il faut le
faire en douceur alors il y a une
proposition et je vais vous demander de
réagir à cette proposition c'est pas
très nouveau mais bon voilà c'est
François Ruffin député la France
insoumise de la somme qui propose
d'indexer les salaires sur l'inflation
on l'écoute première proposition
indexation des salaires sur l'inflation
ce qui existait jusqu'en 1982 l'échelle
mobile des salaires c'est-àdire qu'il y
a pas que le SMIC on peut estimer que
peut-être jusqu'à 2000 € ça augmente
automatiquement première chose et le
travail payera mieux deuxième chose un
blocage des prix temporaires je le dis
quand on interroge les économistes le
blocage des prix dans la durée ça ne
marche pas ça finit par craquer mais un
blocage des prix temporaires gère gère
une situation rodolp bonas je commence
par la fin blocage des prix temporaire
illusoire possible à mon avis illusoire
et on tombe un peu pour moi dans un peu
la la si vous voulez la chimère de dire
finalement pour sortir d'une situation
de crise comme celle-ci seul moyen c'est
encore plus de de mesures j'allais dire
d'un commerce administré or plus vous
encadrez plus vous administrez le
commerce moins quelque part vous pouvez
obtenir le jeu de cette fameuse libre
concurrence et on le voit bien le
gouvernement s est un petit peu cassé
les dents parce que quand Bruno Le Maire
annonce que il souhaite avancer les
dates de négociation commerciales entre
distributeurs industriel c'est
simplement qu'il explique que
l'administration l'organisation de ces
négociations c'est plus possible et et
et c'est pour ça qu'ti le libre commerce
c'est ce qu'on décrivait au tout début
du débat des des des marques profitent
pour augmenter leur marge ou réduire le
le poids des produits proposé au même
prix pardon mais heureusement qu'on
administre un peu quoi je suis tout à
fait d'accord avec vous c'est important
que ce soit encadré ça il y a pas de
débat et l'encadrement est un élément
important mais l'administration
c'est-à-dire le fait de rentrer dans
quelque chose de tellement dogmatique
que finalement la loi du marché ne
s'applique plus je pense qu'à mon avis
il faut y faire attention d'accord alors
je vais aller dans votre sens là j'ai
critiqué vre mais je vais aller dans
votre sens aussi c'est vrai parce
qu'elle belle qu'on a pris cette
habitude depuis on va dire le covid
d'avoir un gouvernement qui est sommé de
trouver une réponse économique à une une
loi ou une mesure dès que dès que
l'inflation augmente ou que et cetera et
cetera donc on est jusqu'où on peut
aller dans une économie administrée donc
voà là je reprends un peu votre argument
oui non c'est vrai que le citoyen a du
mal à comprendre parce que pendant le
covid on a pu finalement donner beaucoup
d'aide mais ça s'est fait dans tous les
pays donc ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est
qu'on est sur un marché international et
qu'il faut en effet que nos mesures nous
pénalisent pas plus par rapport à
l'extérieur donc c'est un peu ça qui est
difficile à comprendre mais c'est vrai
qu'il y a quand même ce sujet de
l'alimentation où il y a pas eu d'aide
en fait alors qu'on a eu des aides
deschecs pour la partie énergie et que
cette inflation sur l'alimentation elle
est plus tardive qu'ailleurs d'ailleurs
que dans les autres pays européens et
elle se fait après la hausse de
l'énergie donc tous ceux qui en fait ce
qu'il y a de difficile c'est que ça ça
touche pas les mêmes parties de la
population donc les segments de la
population qui ont des familles qui ont
des enfants ont une inflation L C la
mesurer hein il y a 4 et5i % d'écart on
n pas égau devant l'inflation devant
l'inflation donc quand c'est il y a les
foyers qui vivent en région parisienne
c'est c'est c'est quatre points et demi
de moins dans la Glob parisienne que
ceux qui vivent dans les zones rurales
et les plus jeunes c'est une inflation
aussi qui est plus faible que ceux qui
sont plus âgés parce que ça concerne
tous les Français qui ont pas d'autre
choix que de prendre leur voiture c'est
par exemple c'est l' des argum et puis
que le poids du logement est plus
important quand on se chauffe et qu'on a
une grande maison et on a un poids de
l'alimentation beaucoup plus élevé quand
on a une famille que quand on vit tout
seul on va parler d'essens dans un
instant mais ça veut dire qu'il faut des
mesures ciblées et pas des mesures
globales c'est ça oui parce que oui le
blocage pourquoi pas d'ailleurs si on
bloque on peut indexer hein çare n parce
que du
coup RZ à la proposition en fait ok mais
sinon oui face à cette crise vous avez
deux solutions soit on encadre les prix
c'est ce qu'on a fait nous en France on
a mis un bouclier soit les autres pays
en fait ont laissé l'inflation mais ils
ont donné un chèque à leurs citoyens ou
à leur entreprise d'un point de vue
budgétaire c'est la même chose la
question qu'on doit se poser c'est qui
paye c'est la même chose c'est l'État
qui paye la question c'est est-ce qu'on
utilise mieux l'argent public en
laissant l'inflation et en compensant
les personnes alors l'avantage c'est ce
que ce qui vient d'être dit c'est que
vous pouvez cibler vous pouvez cibler à
qui vous donnez et à qui vous donnez pas
alors que quand vous encadrez vous
bloquez ah vous ok pour tout le monde y
compris pour des ménages qui n'en ont
pas besoin donc en terme de ciblage on
préfère la stratégie on va dire
allemande en revanche la stratégie
française a un intérêt tout de même
c'est de bloquer c'est ce qu'on a fait
c'estàd que les salaires du coup
progressent moins vite qu'ailleurs
puisque l'inflation a été plus faible et
quand vous le faites pendant 2 ans 2 ans
et demi et ben ça fait que des niveaux
de salaire aujourd'hui en France sont 5
points en dessous du niveau de salaire
allemand ça fait des petits gain de
compétitivité à terme donc en gros c'est
un peu une stratégie cice compétitivité
en bloquant les PR pr mais il y a même
la question qui paye et là c'est les
finances publiques ce que veut le
gouvernement c'est bloquer sans que ça
soit les finances publiques pay et donc
il demande de faire justement des ventes
à perte
et voà vous êtes trop fort vous m'offrez
la transition parce que c'est le thème
de la chronique de Quentin calm tout de
suite il va me rejoindre sur ce plateau
bonsoir Quentin effectivement c'est
l'annonce du weekend bienvenue
gouvernement qui souhaite autoriser
temporairement la vente de carburant à
perdre je le disais tout à l'heure ça
nous ramène quand même 60 ans en arrière
1963 c'est cela Thomas en fait ce qu'on
comprend c'est que l'exécutif espère
faire baisser les prix mais sans sortir
le carnet de chèque et c'est vrai qu'on
l'a vu dans de nombreux départements le
prix du litre qui atteint presque les 2
€ c'est la situation que vivent de
nombreux Français en ce moment quand ils
font le plein et en plus la situation
pourrait empirer dans les prochains mois
les pays producteurs ont déjà annoncé
avoir décidé de réduire le nombre de
barils sur sur le marché afin aussi he
de maintenir leur niveau de rentre et
donc on a vu effectivement ce weekend
dans Le Parisien la première ministre
annoncé revenir sur la loi de 1963 qui
interdit la vente à perte elle a dit je
vous annonce qu'à titre exceptionnel sur
le carburant et sur une période limitée
de quelques mois nous allons lever cette
interdiction ce qui permettra aux
distributeurs de baisser davantage les
prix avec cette mesure inédite
continue-telle nous aurons des résultats
tangibles pour les Français sans
subventionner le carb
l'idée serait donc Thomas d'autoriser
les distributeurs à vendre moins cher
que le prix d'achat la mesure devrait
être ajouté un projet de loi qui sera
présenté dans les prochains prochaines
semaines au Parlement écoutez les
précisions ce matin du ministre de
l'économie sur France
2 sera effectif à partir de début
décembre j'espère le 1er décembre
puisque le texte de loi sera examiné à
l'assemblé début octobre le temps qu'il
soit adopté cette mesure entrera en
vigueur le 1er décembre pour combien
temps elle durera 6 mois en tout cas
c'est la proposition que nous ferons au
parlementaires et ça permettra
effectivement de trouver en fonction de
ce que les distributeurs peuv faire des
carburants moins chers partout en France
c'est ça notre objectif alors fait
plusieurs questions d'abord que vont
devenir les petites stations
indépendantes ben c'est vrai que c'est
la question Thomas regardez comment se
compose le marché en ce moment en France
les stations de service sont détenus à
moitié par la grande distribution 5200
des 11000 stations appartiennent à ces
encenes comme Intermarché au carrefour
3400 sont gérés par Total et environ
2500 sont indépendantes ces indépendants
justement il fustige la mesure regardez
leur représentant qui s'est exprimé dans
les colonnes du Figaro baisser les prix
chez nous c'est impossible nos stations
se font nos stations se font à 1 ou 2
centimes net de marge et en amont les
distributeurs se font des pouillemes de
centimes donc c'est aussi petit qu'un
pou oui d'accord je connaissais pas ce
mot moi non plus je l'ai appris en
lisant cette interview avant de nous
vendre le carburant on ne pourra pas
s'aligner disent les indépendants et
même dans les autres enseignes les
experts du secteur sont sceptiques pour
les autres enseignes parce que les
moyennes et les grandes surfaces font
des marges assez faibles sur le
carburant et donc elles pourrai
finalement répercuter les baisses de
prix du carburant sur leurs autres
produits ce qui est certain Thomas c'est
que ça prépare une guerre des prix à
partir du mois de décembre merci
beaucoup Quentin rodol bon je me tourne
vers vous c'est la grande distribution
potentiellement qui qui pourrait
appliquer ces ventes à perte oui ce sont
les seuls qui ont les moyens par
d'autres revenus d'arriver à financer
ses baisses et ses ventes à perte alors
je dois vous avouer qu'en tant
qu'observateur du milieu je suis
absolument abasourdi parce que c'est on
revient sur un dogme he c'est-à-dire
vous savez qu'en France la vente à perte
est très encadrée normalement parce que
seul pendant les périodes de solde les
commerçants sont autorisés à vendre leur
produits à perte donc là aujourd'hui il
faudrait imaginer qu'une qu'une enseigne
de grande distribution utilise l'essence
comme étant un tracteur de trafic si
vous voulez he c'est déjà un peu le cas
aujourd'hui oui c'est pour ça que
aujourd'hui souvent l'essence dans les
grandes et moyennes surfaces est vendu
comme on appelle à prix coûtant de façon
à dire bah voilà on a pas de marge
dessus mainant je vous donne juste un
chiffre il faut savoir qu'un hypermarché
c'est à peu près 30000 L d'essence
vendue par jour donc vous faites vite le
calcul si jamais on décide de baisser 10
% bah ça fait 3000 € par jour de 10
centimes pardon si ça fait 20 centimes
ça fera 6000 € par jour c'est quasiment
intenable de tenir sur la durée donc on
n'est peut-être pas à l'abri de une ou
deux opérations commerciales un peu
fortes sur très courte durée pour créer
beaucoup de trafic mais ça sera pas
durable ça tient pas économiquement une
autre réaction d' d'un membre du
gouvernement sur sur cette mesure
c'était Olivier verrand sur RTL hier sur
le on va dire la risourne potentielle
c'est peut-être un peu emballé on
l'écoute ce que propose la première
ministre c'est pragmatique c'est dire
ceux qui le souhaitent ceux qui le
peuvent lors d'opération spécial par
exemple pourront vendre de l'essence à
prix cassé mais vraiment cassé on parle
quasiment d'un demieuro potentiellement
de moins par
litre ça vous a un peu fait rire il il
c'est c'est ça n'atteindra jamais ce
niveau-là er enfin bon voilà vous avez
raison j'aurais dû poser la question
différ probable en tout cas c'est c'est
très peu probable et bien la question ça
fait longtemps qu'on a pas utilisé un
anglicisme mais là c'est mais il y a pas
de free lunch il y a bien quelqu'un qui
va payer ça voyez al c'est soit ça
l'État et donc là aujourd'hui
effectivement il y a certains qui
peuvent se se passer mais ça va soit ils
vont le répercuter dans d'autres prix
soit ça veut dire ça va se payer sur des
indépendants donc attention et moi je
pense qu'aujourd'hui entre nous le faire
alors que le prix du baril il est pas
non plus extrêmement élevé voyez on
tourne aux alentours de 90 et il va pas
baisser donc ça veut dire quoi il a été
beaucoup plus haut que ça il a été
nettement plus haut en 2008 il était à
120 120 dollars pendant la crise donc on
comprend pas l'urgence de ce point de
vuel parce que vous voyez si à chaque
fois qu'il a 90 on met des on autorise
de de la vente perte alors ça qu'on va
dire ça va être la nouvelle norme on va
autoriser systémaement que là on est en
train de s'habituer au 19,99 chez Total
qui bouge jamais donc le jour où ça
dépasse les deux tout le monde va
absolument pas une solution à long terme
et donc et on n'est pas dans une crise
comme on a pu l'être il y a même 1 an ou
2 ans on est sur une mesure juste
politique avec deux sujets très
cristallisants un l'alimentaire parce
qu'on fait ses courses une à deux fois
par semaine et deux l'essence parce
qu'on y va une à deux fois par semaine
et ça le gouvernement doit s'y attaquer
parce que c'est ce qui fait mal aux
Français c'est pas forcément ce qui pèse
le pouir mais c'est ce qui fait mal le
français ou donc il faut une réponse
politique Anne Catherine Loisier votre
avis sur ce ce retour à 1963 est-ce
qu'il faut revenir 60 ans en arrière oui
non je suis aussi dubitatif que les
intervenants parce qu'effectivement qui
va payer hein euh si si je je crains que
comme en parallèle on parle de revenir
sur l'encadrement des des produits
d'hygiène et alimentaire et bien ce soit
effectivement la contrepartie et puis
par ailleurs je suis étonnée parce que
sur l'alimentaire et bien le
gouvernement préconise un seuil de
revente perd plus 10 ce que le sujet sur
lequel le Cénat interroge depuis
quelques temps puisque là on sur tous
les produits de grande consommation
alimentaire on pratique le seuil de
revente à perte plus 10 obligatoirement
donc il y a quand même un paradoxe comme
le disait votre intervenant à proposer
des des ventes à perte sur le carburant
et à proposer des ventes avec seuil de
revente à perte plus 10 sur
l'alimentaire je je merci beaucoup je me
tourne vers vous toujours sur cette
question parce qu'elle est belle estce
que j'ai bien compris mais je voudrais
qu'on
soit précis quoi le risque il faudra que
les consommateurs soient vigilant
j'allais dire aware mais on a dit qu'on
arrêtait les
anglicismes soit vigilant sur sur les
prix c'estd que ce qu'ils vont gagner à
la pompe ils vont peut-être le perdre
sur les produits cosmétiques par exemple
attention faites fait attentionour oui
c'est comme ça que fonctionne la grande
distribution des promotions c'est qu'en
effet ils gagne sur un autre rayon et on
sait que souvent c'est sur les fruits et
les légumes ou les prix sont plus élevés
que ce qui est ce que coûte le produit
donc si ils y arrivent eux c'est c'est
bien parce qu'ils vont ils vont
récupérer sur d'autres produits et comme
ça vient d'être dit en ce moment et
c'est ce qui va se passer aussi dans le
cosmétique c'est qu'on a on fait des
lois pour que le on soit à 10 %
au-dessus du du seuil de vente à perte
ce qui a été fait pour mieux rémunérer
les agriculteurs et mieux rémunérer les
industriels du côté des des cosmétiques
donc en effet on comprend pas bien
pourquoi pour le pétrole on autoriserait
une vente à perte alors que dans
d'autres secteurs on pourrait faire un
un stop sur la loi égalime plutôt on
pourrait se dire
exception sur une loi qui est récente et
qu'on arrêterait pendant quelques temps
et ça permettrait d'avoir des prix
alimentaires qui baisseraient vraiment
ouais c'est le thème dont je voulais
parler maintenant la loi égalime et je
me retourne vers vous Anne-Catherine
Loisier puisque vous êtes rapporteur du
Comité de suivi de cette loi égalime au
au Sénat qui prévoit on va dire alors je
va la la simplifier mais meilleur
rémunération des producteurs
réquilibrage et relations commerciales
entre industriels et distributeurs
est-ce qu'elle a rajouter de la rigidité
finalement et peut-être un peu
d'inflation à l'inflation aujourd'hui
oui c'est ça a été évoqué hein nous
c'est ce que nous avons pointé d dès
2018 dès l'examen de la première loi
égalime c'est en fait ce risque d'effets
collatéraux les distribuurs
distributeurs aillant chercher ailleurs
les les efforts qu'on leur demanderait
sur les produits alimentaires euh donc
et et et en fait on on a vu s'enchaîner
les lois puisque là la la loi qui va
arrivver ne portera pas que que sur
l'alimentaire mais on on l'appelle d'ors
et déjà les galimcat pour essayer à
chaque fois de corriger les abus les
effets collatéraux voir même les
contournements he d'un certain nombre
d'industriels donc je je partage l'avis
qui a été évoqué c'est que je crois
qu'aujourd'hui on on va trop loin en
matière de de de législation et
d'ailleurs elle est unique en Europe
cette législation égal nos voisins n'en
ont pas alors on peut on peut commenter
l'inflation chez nos voisins est-ce que
finalement la loi égal mais tous les
dispositifs qu'on a pu mettre en en
place se sont révélés
efficaces en tout cas nous au Sénat on
s'interroge là-dessus et depuis l'année
dernière on on souhaite avoir plus de
transparence là aussi sur la manière
dont sont utilisées les sommes récoltées
entre guillemets par les distributeurs
dans le cadre du SRP + 10 nous n'avons
toujours pas cette information il devait
remettre des rapports au gouvernement au
1er septembre SRP seuil de revente à
perte he c'est ça vous disz tout à
l'heure donc il devait faire un bilan et
donner le détail de l'utilisation de ces
sommes est-ce qu'elles vont
effectivement aux agriculteur comme
c'était prévu initialement nous n'avons
toujours pas ces éléments d'accord votre
avis parce que je vouais réagir sûr je
je je partage sur le fait qu'aujourd'hui
cette loi égalim elle a montré ses
limites je vais vous donner deux
chiffres savoir que l'encadrement des
promotion commerciale vous savez
qu'aujourd'hui vous pouvez pas avoir une
promotion commerciale qui dépasse 34 %
c'est vous pouvez avoir deux produits
achetés le troisième gratuit mais vous
pouvez plus avoir un produit acheté un
produit gratuit bah ça sur le pouvoir
d'achat des Français ça a pesé 1
milliard et dem dem d'euros hein
c'estàdire que nous on a on a une
générosité des marques qui a baissé près
de près de 1 milliard et demi et on est
en train de vouloir le remettre en œuvre
cette fois-ci sur les produits non
alimentaires avec la fameuse loi des
croisag je sais pas si vous avez entendu
parler de cette loi et c'est la même
chose c'est dire on va encadrer le
système et au bout du bout nous les
consommateurs on risque de payer
certains produits plus chers je reviens
à la la loi la partie on va dire
alimentaire l'objectif c'était mieux
rémunérer les producteurs les
agriculteurs si simplifie est-ce que ça
a marché c'est extrêmement compliqué à
lire parce que c'éit un dispositif de
ruissellement hein l'idée étant de dire
bah finalement on arrive à collecter
plus de marges sur des produits en
particulier les grandes marques national
les fameuses pattes à tartiner les sodas
ou autres lessives de façon à faire en
sorte que cet argent qui fabrique de la
marche sur la vente de ces produits
puisse aller directement aux au aux
agriculteurs c'est très difficile à lire
le seul élément sur lequel on est
certain que que l'argent va dans la
poche des agriculteurs malheureusement
c'est l'année 2022 qui nous permet de le
lire parce que pour une fois les marges
de nos agriculteurs ont augmenté
uniquement pourquoi parce que les
produits des matières premières brutes
ont fortement augmenté sur l'année 2022
alors là pour le coup quand les courses
sont élevé les agriculteurs gagnent la
stratégie du rissellement très
honnêtement aujourd'hui on y voit
toujours pas clair alors je je reste sur
le la question des agriculteurs parce
que là aussi on est au cœur du d'un
débat sur l'inflation l'un des effets de
cette inflation c'est que les Français
beaucoup de Français et on les comprend
ils achètent plus de produits d'entrée
de gamme Erer et les agriculteurs
français sont pas les mieux placés sur
ces produits d'entrée de gamme donc ils
nous disent attention on est en train de
perdre des parts de marché à toute
vitesse est-ce qu'ils ont raison de dire
ça est-ce qu'ils forcent un peu le trait
ah enfin on on le saura euh avec
certitude dans quelques moi mais oui je
pense qu'il effectivement et ça c'est
pas très bien analysé par l'INC
lorsqu'il mesure l'inflation parce que
vous voyez l'inflation c'est on prend le
panier de consommation euh de de du du
ménagere et on regarde commence à
augmenter mais si vous changez
énormément votre structure de
consommation bah l'INC ne ne le fait pas
attention parce qu'il ne change pas le
panier régulièrement et donc
possiblement là on surévalue l'inflation
par rapport à ou pour une fois on peut
dire une bonne nouvelle peut-être qu' y
a un peu moins d'inflation parce qu'on
est allé effectivement chercher des
produits de d'une qualité inférieure et
donc d'un prix inférieur mais
effectivement il y a encore une fois pas
de freelun il a bien quelqu'un qui paye
et ce quelqu'un là c'est effectivement
l'agriculteur français qui n'est pas
dans le bas de gamme et plutôt dans dans
une gamme assez élevée avec des
conséquences de santé publique parce
qu'elle est belle il faut quand même
dire ça aussi que ce sont des produits
de moins bonne qualité peut-être moins
de consommation de fruits de légumes
parce queil coûte plus cher on est c'est
c'est c'est un peu ce qu'on voit ce
qu'on voit plusieurs mois oui ce qu'il y
a c'est que dès que on a une inflation
trop forte on diversifie beaucoup moins
son alimentation et alors qu'on avait
réussi à faire augmenter les
consommations de fruits de légumes
aujourd'hui ça diminue en fait on voit
bien que en effet il y a des imports qui
sont plus importants par exemple sur la
viande le cheptel a beaucoup beaucoup
diminué et on importe beaucoup de de
produits sur la viande c'est du steak
haché qui est consommé donc en effet
c'est pas les les morceaux les les plus
intéressants qui sont en hausse donc il
y a vraiment cette question de long
terme qui est que en ayant une inflation
forte pendant longtemps les Français
vont moins bien manger ils augmentent
leur consommation de féculant c'est ce
qui permet de se nourrir pour pas cher
et donc on va manger moins de produits
qui nous permettent d'être en meilleur
état de santé et donc on va le payer
dans quelques années on sait que les
enfants mangent moins bien vont manger
tous les jours la même chose et donc
finalement on tient pas compte de ces
effets là de long terme de mauvaise
alimentation qui qui se fait en ce
moment ça se rejoint bonas le bio est en
train de de
oui pe triial maisf très très grand pour
est en forte baisse et malheureusement
là encore pour le coup si vous me
permettez de encore tirer la sonnette
d'alarme pour ces agriculteurs que l'on
a poussé vers la transition du bio qui
ont mis de TR années à investir des
dizaines voir même centaines de milliers
d'euros pour passer en agriculture bio
et aujourd'hui qui se retrouve à vendre
du lait entre guillemets bio au prix du
traditionnel là je pense qu'il y a
urgence là pour le coup il faut vraiment
s'occuper de ces agriculteurs là mais
oui vous vous avez raison les
consommateurs aujourd'hui et bien
finalement arbitrent et malheureusement
pas toujours dans le sens de la qualité
merci à tous d'avoir participé à ce
débat qui était vraiment passionnant on
a appris beaucoup de choses grâce à vous
et pas seulement des anglicismes je m'en
excuse encore une fois je vous dis à
demain pour un nouveau numéro de sens
publ et noté que François patria le
président de des sénateurs Renaissance
sera l'invité Dorian mansini demain 8h
dans la matinale belle
soirée
[Musique]